well isn't gentleman waiting for Will
Sasso and [ __ ] is late as usual he's
always a half hour late 100% there's no
question I'll get a text that says boy
this place is far away huh you've been
here before
Sasso my buddy Nate shomer has got a
show on Animal Planet called from rescue
dog - Superdog
hoping for a second season he trained my
dogs he wanted to come in and watch the
pod cast cuz he's a fan so while we wait
for will I'm gonna ask Nate a bunch of
questions about dogs
dude he took my dogs for two weeks and
basically they came back and they were
doing calculus derivatives they were
like they were talking it was it was
crazy what's the smartest dog what's the
smartest breed of dog right now
yeah smartest dog it's it's pretty
arguable a lot of people will say that
the border collie is the smartest dog I
mean it's incredibly capable can learn
so many different commands but then we
also want to look at train ability which
dog is the most trainable I personally
love the Belgian Malinois because
they're so driven so motivated and even
though they're not as smart as the
border collie they can still accomplish
some incredible tasks because that
driving motivation so so if the a zombie
apocalypse comes oh I want a melon or
you want a mound
oh yeah they're gonna inhale they're
gonna inhale you're anybody who comes
after you
oh you ever do they love it - really
that's the best part right you know I
mean we've talked about protection
training and bite work and stuff like
that before and you know there's this
misconception that the dogs don't enjoy
it right but you've seen it and what's
your take on it they they they like
biting that sleeve more than they like
any kind of food you could possibly give
them
oh yeah there's it's like it's like you
know I mean it's almost like sex like
the way like if you had this beautiful
woman and they were like don't touch her
and you haven't had sex in ten years
like they'll freak out like those those
serious game bred are those sort of like
prey Drive dogs those those police dogs
they're they're biting they're clicking
their teeth at like noon and then you
you present the sleeve and they hit it
like like this zero hesitation that's
like the best analogy I think I've ever
heard for that yeah it's hilarious I
mean I love doing it it's an incredibly
fun sport it's very
to work out oh yeah I mean you you of
course you're gonna sweat a ton and get
a great workout and you've got a great
potty namely it was a marine for nine
years
a real marine to be exact seven years
and seven months black belt which is a
win in marine martial arts yeah I mean
any black belt in jujitsu is gonna kick
my butt even the purple belts blue belts
kick my butt I don't give a [ __ ] man you
trained dogs and you're a marine you're
a stud so it's what we saying so so what
was I saying something about the melon
why I believe okay wait so Malin was for
the zombie apocalypse what about an
Eastern German line German Shepherd or a
Rottweiler you have to I mean German
Shepherds can make fantastic dogs
especially when it comes to having a
family or like a protection dog because
they have that on and off switch so they
can go out there they can do the work
arguably as good as a Malinois but then
they do have that off switch they can
relax they can cut it with the family
but that's not to say that a mountain
walk can't do that either
well and I have a Malin wine she will
snuggle up with anyone it doesn't really
yeah but she often might bite you in the
face I don't know well I don't teach her
to bite in the face but she blows the
bite suit she loves the tug toys and she
has do it it's more of a game for her
it's not if I Drive yeah it's a game for
all of them I mean what I tell people
when somebody comes out on a bite sued
the dogs not looking to bite that person
that's not their intent although some
are don't get me wrong especially police
dogs they got a training for that more
civil type work but a lot of the dogs
that I work with their sport dogs you
know if they accidentally bite your hand
let's say they immediately let go and
they go oh sorry sorry I did not mean to
bite your hand should we go back and so
then that's not cuz I when I was in
Afghanistan I of guys done I
I put on a bite suit and that these
melon was and when they had the mound
was in the cage they were like no they
were going crazy I was like do not open
that case again now don't worry about
the midday of the case they came out and
they were like they were fine right like
I thought they were trying to get at me
they were barking and trying to bite at
the case the minute they open the case
that the dog came out circled around and
it was just kind of like sniffing and I
was like dude the thing was literally
looking me in the eye trying to kill me
all those handlers have good control I'm
assuming yeah well but then again so
they put on we put on the bite suit but
I didn't have a helmet and I was like
shouldn't I have my head
now they won't bite your hand so for
them it was kind of a game mm-hmm but
how do you get the dog from going like
like in a real-life situation if
somebody's hitting them or shooting a
gun or actually trying to hurt them or
you how do you get that dog to transfer
that and there's a lot of different ways
that trainers will work with dogs to get
them to that point of being an actual
protection dog or a police dog or a
military dog the trainings going to be a
little bit different a lot of the
foundation work is the same getting the
dog to love the training and getting the
dog to do a full bite to hold on there's
a lot to it but even with you know
police canine training there's a lot of
different aspects that they have to look
at something I believe it's called I
could be getting this wrong so if
anybody is listening to this and they're
an expert when it comes to police k-9
training I apologize but they have
something that's called like the blue
fog so they teach the dogs when they
bite not to let go at all because they
don't want the dog to let go the bite
and redirect on a police officer and
they don't want the dog chewing because
if the dog is chewing on the criminal
that was trying to escape or whatever
then that's a huge liability issue if
the person has like 30 bites on their
arm it should the one where they lock
down police come in they arrest the
suspect and then they take the dog off
that's like my friend who got in a fight
with all these cops in Philly and that's
a bad drunk he's in China and he kicked
he kicked the dog in the ass and the dog
redirected on a dude across the street
who was running oh wow and took that
dude down and that's why he got off
because there was such a lawsuit that
the cops didn't the Philly police didn't
want this huge like lawsuit and all this
publicity but the dog redirected because
my friend grabbed a cop threw the cop
threw the cop on the dog as it was
coming out of me saw that day he saw
them let the dog through the go from the
truck and then he kicked the dog in the
ass if you know my friend you understand
this by his big big there's an article
like there's an article framed of a
woman a cop the huge woman in in a neck
brace because she was part of the meal a
and I think it was before they had
tasers I don't know what it was but this
is like in the 80s when he was playing
football oh wow and he's if you know him
he's he was to Stewie and six - and it
was all muscle and he could dunk a
basketball he was really strong you know
one of those [ __ ] guys
you can taste him and he's like ah [ __ ]
and he grabs it out and yeah like some
dudes this doesn't work he was like I
know guys like that where he was one of
those guys who would um like he was at a
football game and they had a they had a
dog there and he was staring at it I
wasn't there but my friend was like what
are you looking at he goes I'm looking
about I'm looking at that dog and he
goes what are you looking at he goes I
kill that dog and they go well what do
you mean he goes I'm just thinking that
that dog came at me like what I would do
and his friend goes what would you doing
this I think I kick his legs out and
then and then when I fell on the ground
I'd like I jump on it not strangling and
he was he was trying to go through the
whole the motions of what he would do
have you ever heard of it makes me think
of uh I was talking to somebody who's an
incredible MMA fighter and he said you
know there's been times where I've taken
somebody who only worked you know let's
say one specific martial arts and he's
like and I hit him a couple times and
their belt level starts to drop because
that panic sets in because they're not
used to actually being that's just
saying that they have they say they say
with your black belt in just jujitsu
like MMA guys will be like they go are
your black belt brown belt right exactly
yeah red belt right you know what I
can't member the belts but you know
about blue belt wipeouts you know punch
you five times and you go right back
down to my white belt and that's what I
think is very similar to with like a dog
I've had a lot of people tell me oh I
could take on a protection trained dog
or a police dog and I'm thinking to
myself no you most likely you can't when
that dog comes and rips off your tricep
all the sudden your perspective
completely changes my eye you're just
screaming for help
[ __ ] yes I mean my buddy who's a SWAT
sergeant said that to me they he
deployed a dog on I shouldn't have seen
this but I did on this this giant green
beret guy I saw he was here two cops in
a canal and in in Florida and he was
basically fighting them and drown him
and he let his dog go that dog grabbed
his arm the top of his arm he had he had
huge arm but he shut down I go what
happened he goes my dog's a wolf bro
it's a 100 pound Shenron when it grabs
on the nerve shut down your arm shuts
down you're not you're not fighting that
dog yeah that's an animal that's 100
pound wolf that's got crazy pounds
square-inch pressure and i don't think
people realize i've I felt a Malinois
bite on through the site and I panicked
no we have it on videotape dub Davidoff
the comic was like get it off me get
your wolf off me he was freaking out
they bite like I couldn't believe the
pressure just in the bite suit and
that's a funny will [ __ ] sass so
ladies and gentlemen Seth will sasso
knate knate knate show Murr Nate Nate
summer and I are taki cuz you were late
Nate amen no take that get that get that
sign off bro get that sign up what's up
man all right there take hey take it
easy bro ah what are you doing what are
you doing man
Will Sasso Nate I want to thank you for
making an appearance on the fighter and
kid welcome the man no alright take it
hey I'm just here to co-host the show
sitting in for Brennan's job big ready
shots got the big brown breakdown check
it out
brat Brandon's got a new no don't talk
about well he's got a new line of socks
nope he does brown socks no I don't
think he did brown socks check out your
big brown socks big brown socks calm the
brown Pig and their socks so if you have
over a size 17 foot you're gonna want
big Browns wick away moisture technology
all right we got big shitty stinky
sweaty feet like me now Brian you know I
wear a size 22 and I will put it through
your face so keep at me about being late
I won't hang a sign on the door I'm
supposed to walk through ever again I do
take that as an offense okay then listen
up big brown Sascha only way to get your
big brown breakdown not an advertiser
for brown sounds [ __ ] socks listen up
maybe you would try to bring that foot
habit you didn't know Brown has been 87
shades of brown listen up we got 150 you
reach my face with your foot cuz I move
so quickly and I can measure distance
and you and kick and you to overstep and
then your [ __ ] face would be and I
would go back yeah yeah I go boop boop
boop
I understand combinations boop boop yes
wack and then you go
okay [ __ ] your pants how did your pants
enough to run away hey how did that guy
what was that guy the Crocodile Hunter
rock it out Dundee no the guy the beaver
passed away Steven Irwin Steve alright
now how did he die
I'm already annoyed with this giant
[ __ ] water bottle of yours man you
drink too much water broke you just do
you drink too much water you can't
excuse me drink enough water I can't
take it how did you see one guy he had
he got he tried to pet a stingray from
what I understand yeah and it's shot
it's it's barb into his heart and God
bless the man he passed away
how BIG's a stingray I don't know will
was probably a very big stingray
probably had a wingspan of about six to
eight feet okay now we're gonna go ahead
and say we're gonna go ahead and put the
over-under at under when we say that my
foot is the size of a stingray it's
probably a little smaller right it's a
little smaller but not by much I don't
know I don't believe in getting
pedicures okay
so if you come close to me and I'm just
wagging my foot around and I just send a
gnarled yellow toenail don't into your
chest I cut you don't don't I cut your
nail okay you bleed out no I'm not
touching you get your finger this is a
lot of gas getting there the [ __ ] bro
I'm warning you I can't be on the
telephone no I can push I can be pushed
so far Oh only be pushed so far see all
right well what's up man not much first
of all welcome back from candidate you
think very much you spent too much time
in Canada I don't know where the [ __ ]
you were you spent too much time I did I
went to Canada for way too long
yeah and the other thing you guys need
to know is that will Chris D'Elia and
Marshall are we're all on a thread
Marshall they know Marshall Marshall
Marshall cooker you know Marshall he's
our buddy
yeah a good buddy Marshall cook mmm
writer director extraordinaire Marshall
come hey we just finished a script yeah
I know you know we want to know we just
rewrote a script so we're gonna need you
to get that to patty Jenkins yeah
and Todd Phillips yeah and grill oh yeah
we're just gonna need you to get it
we're gonna need to get media to get
around that's my mom's I got long arms
so I can do that okay cool I need you to
I'm not gonna need you to do some
clerical duties for me now
today once we finish up with your pod
show we're gonna sit down and we are
going to I'm gonna sit over I'm gonna
sit over your shoulder no no and I'm
gonna drink you're gonna make me a
protein shake I'm not a kid hanging
protein shake that's gonna make my
breath bad no nice and I'm gonna sit
over your shoulder go yeah not if I'm
patty Jenkins know is that her Jean is a
gmail I'm not agreeing to that and
that's what I would like you to do for
the rest of the day you're gonna do some
clerical duties being rude gonna get
this amazing script out and the next
time yeah I come on the fighter in the
kid in the man I'll call them we're
gonna I'm gonna tell you about all the
wonderful strides we've made in getting
this script out there and doing the
movie you know getting a movie made
because that's what [ __ ] matters
right is making movies not hanging out
in Canada with my adorable little
parents is that my friends and family
well you were that's not what matters
you're come down to Hollywood everybody
take anything oh I came back here and
I'm like of course I should be here in
my house all by myself oh what a great
time all right
oh I'm so glad that I'm pursuing my
career make it easy bro this is not if
you don't long I've been in show
business
probably fifty-two years I hear that all
52 years now showbiz feels that way for
you right now cuz you're not having a
good time
well I'm having a great time actually
things are going swell you're not gonna
talk about that because I love your
listeners I enjoy coming on the podcast
anytime I'm on the podcast and you have
a wonderful and loyal listener she do we
do not want harming - yeah they are and
we don't want to hear them going like
that [ __ ] talked about this for too
much or that for too much I'm perfectly
fine to let you drive yeah no I was just
tired of sending them no I was thinking
about something that I saw on TV no
you're already trying to be the alpha
male on this no no I don't that's that
[ __ ] either comes naturally well or it
doesn't okay
don't [ __ ] I'm an alpha too so that's
the thing don't yeah but don't look with
you know what because I don't like your
body because I'm not gonna sit up to I'm
not afraid to fight you and I'll say
that right now you you're sitting oh you
gotta you need your nose under you don't
think now it's mine to get you up don't
tell what I think man ass like me okay I
got a big fat man oh god yeah what what
do you do with that what my big fat man
you ever have a girl be honest with me
you ever have a woman cuz I know you see
you get you get girls sometimes that
like their big man they like a big man
yeah bad woman get get except just work
work your ass work my ass I know what I
asked you yeah I've had women like stand
on my ass yeah what else you ever have a
girl just need it like dough yeah I need
it like go and ask just get down and
need it yeah or you know hold the edge
of that I have a very regal looking bed
so the head the headboard is very regal
and it goes up there's there's there's
leather there's wood very regal no I
hate that burn down it's men they'll
hold it and then they'll just you know
Gatien my ass with their case vacation
if I get too relaxed and you know a
little size 5 oh no up your [ __ ] it no
well Brian and I used to have a podcast
yeah and it's called the 10-minute pod
right now and it's still on yeah you
were on recently not too long ago
hilarious yeah hilarious and I always
invite your listeners to go check out
the 10 minute podcast yeah
but they better do it quick because we
got something called the diamond ding
happening what's the diamond name well
boy the origins of the diamond ding lie
in my good pals who do the podcast with
me now good no I just you know I got a
diamond shaped piss hole you do have a
diamond shaped this way I know I got a
real pistol you've got a Brian has the
widest piss hole I got a piss hole Brian
takes a piss I can piss and come he keep
me he'll like he'll come and piss and do
it all in around 20 seconds yeah hildie
he's told me many a tales it's just for
you I guess this is for you and then
it's just like it's like someone just
like like if you filled like it's a
German and you just went like that if
I'm in a German piss bar for example
right and of course I'm up on one of
them trapezius and I got them perverts
down there oh yeah yeah American peace
yeah yeah I say yeah and they all that's
a piss hole yeah I don't know how you
say that in German they say no
are in the piece hole yep that's what
they say yeah well they reach on their
face and they go mayonnaise ER yeah
mayonnaise in that yeah I got Mayo
Clinic he can pee in like he can take
like a full bladder piss in seven
seconds that's right cuz Bryan's piss
hole looks like you put like a like a
like a like a half inch rebar up his
dick alright tell people and just dug
around in there so it's real you know
what I'm talking about rebar you know
like the big bar yeah the diamond ding
starts with the the origins of the
diamond ding start with you know my good
pals writer producers Chad Kultgen and
Tommy Blocher with whom I do the show
now and we've decided to widdle the
audience down to one listener oh boy one
diamond list I don't understand that
oh it's been happening for a while and
it's getting more and more arcane as a
matter of fact I know that some of the
some of your listeners are people who
listen to a couple podcasts and
occasionally will get you know tweets
and stuff to people listen to both our
pot yes so I guess I'm the point of a
podcast is to grow it and for you guys
you're trying to know Dimond it down
we're trying to get it down to we're
crushing it down like coal to one
diamond listener okay and it's real and
it's happening and there and something
very special that I cannot reveal now
will be happening yeah for real with
that one diamond listener so I am NOT
I'm not even talking but you can tell us
what the reward for being the diamond
listener
no that's gonna be happening throughout
the fall and we will let let it out but
there is a very real reward I think this
is unprecedented
yeah in the world of podcasting and and
I'm not trying to say like YouTube you
think cuz you know every time I'm on
here like the Tim in a podcast you know
and you get upset it's not what I'm
trying to do now what I'm trying to do
is say those of your listeners who
listen to both shows yeah you know who
we appreciate over here the fighter and
the kid and over a 10 minute podcast
please play peas please peg I had a
stroke did you see that that's cuz you
do drugs oh yeah because I don't nothing
but drug fried-chicken drugs and job man
[ __ ] slept in days oh you read my
book I drugs and chicken I didn't read
that
um it's bad one of the worst health
books ever anyway I just want to say
that the people who listened to both
shows pay close attention to what's
happening with the diamond oh man
and some great shit's gonna happen after
it's over because when something dies
something else is born yes it's it's
death and resurrection it's the yin and
the yang from the ashes from the ashes a
Phoenix Phoenix rise rise so we can have
a belongs
speaking of ash in your heart how is god
damn it you're not in the [ __ ] Sudan
bro we're not we're not crossing the
deserts of Namibia that is so spiritual
that's what I do when I'm crossing the
deserts of Namibia I sing that song by
Enya but then do you know do you know
that when you would when you would chase
the Mongols when they would steal your
women and your your your stuff and they
would they would kill a bunch of your
brethren and then they would run back
into the desert and you would mount your
army right you know an army people like
you yeah and you did ancestors that I
feel inside might sing you and log in
you [ __ ] agricultural farmers you
guys would mount you let's get the army
together yeah and you chase them into
the desert you understand oh yeah
because you need a lot of water okay
you would have you'd be able to carry
that water into the desert cuz know that
there's no [ __ ] unless you want to
stick a straw into a [ __ ] cactus yeah
you ain't yank it and your horses or you
watered because you need a lot of water
now listen mm-hmm so you'd follow the
Mongols in now you you can carry 24
hours of water actually it depends I
think it was actually maybe eight days
of water in yeah so you're chasing them
and they're hanging just out of reach
just how to reach and mocking you as
you're like
your [ __ ] water cry and by the way
as you do that your mouth is losing
water right wrong good so and they they
keep quiet but they just hang just out
of reach but you're so furious and they
got your girls and maybe they're like ha
ha we got your girls near yeah you know
and yeah and yeah I'm coming now now how
come they don't have any water well -
exactly why don't I know water you
[ __ ] you watch your mouth you watch
your mouth
historical ignoramus say many hard
things to hit you and I understand that
but just listen up keep your ears open
and your congratulations on their shot
you got a thing over here in the corner
I saw it on now you know that no you're
not done I'm just taking a little pause
to say you have a wonderful thing from
YouTube yeah Congrats on right now
there's 40,000 subscribers fantastic for
them I'll [ __ ] smash your nose with
that huh now so go on good luck because
I came I have a good head movement now
listen I'll take three shots you can
miss the first - you are not gonna
alright what's this thing you catch that
in the head I'll answer back to attach
that and the [ __ ] head I'll lift that
up with one hand don't [ __ ] threaten
to cave my head and threatening anything
right it's your story
all right you historical ignoramus
staged this alright got in touch with me
the man who made this yeah wonderful
artist and he's gonna make another one
for you cuz I'm gonna break that into
two perfect pieces on your nose [ __ ]
that's your story so their talent their
tapping the vein of their horse yeah and
they're living on blood right yeah
okay as the as the Horde would do as you
run out of water you go a guys with four
days in we got to turn back right wrong
but then you because you go [ __ ] to
mud let's [ __ ] keep going they go sir
captain and you go like you interrupt me
because yeah sure sir we've got to turn
back around
no no way I'm too angry sir Brian's
version of me and I'm angry okay so no
we got no we got to keep going sir we if
we turn we don't turn back now we're
gonna run out of water the last day so
we really need to we I don't think we're
gonna catch them and somehow they don't
seem to need water okay here's where
you're wrong
yeah my my agricultural forward society
yeah my ancestors yeah
along a slightly different way we would
be on the Great Plains we would get
attacked by the Mongols yeah you know a
little color would happen they would
take our women yep
you know what I mean changing our
bloodline yeah having said that my
ancestors with all the advancements they
had in agriculture and also farming and
animals they cross bred to animals I
didn't know that yes
now careful because I don't know if this
is historically accurate they cross bred
to animals yeah one animal came from the
great forests mountains and valleys of
Canada
okay now careful because is of course
the moose okay the Moose the Moose is
very fast animal yep
stupid face but yeah it's got a big
stupid face and a dumb nose Dom knows
it's a big animal
look don't just saying I'm not a moose
you guys and so [ __ ] know well
alright so we got the money
what does moose have on his head
sticking out of sculpt a big huge
antlers right we also have a species
that is extinct but can be brought back
what with you know now the advancements
with DNA you know yeah you program the
RNA to tell the DNA what to do you guys
understand that a lot of science fans
that listen to this ok
the woolly mammoths and we cross bred
these animals you guys did or what do
you mean this is back in the day the
woolly moose I mean cross bred and we
would ride the woolly moose yeah in up
to you know three adults and four
children could could ride on one that
tree we can put babies in the antlers
yep and we would save yep and we and the
woolly moose reached up to what you
would now refer to as like you know 90
to 100 and miles per hour and speed
Indrani
yes and now when you say that the the
hoard used to like tap the vein of the
horse
yeah and drink we would we would you
want to talk about a diamond shaped piss
hole yeah a woolly moose has like a piss
hole like that it's like if you do this
with your hands yeah that makes that
diamonds yeah up like DDP you doing your
DDP yoga you don't know what I'm talking
about right now
no because you cover fighting here okay
cover
professional wrestling all right should
he at least do one episode we month on
anyway they got a big huge piss hole
yeah and we just you know we just drink
the water we'd go to the lake and then
we'd stick our face into the the woolly
mooses vaginas custom or for our face
right into their dick yeah and and fill
it with water I and then we would
disguise the kids would ride on the back
and scoop it with the ladle and we would
have water for weeks just drink we just
drink bully moose piss water and we
would cross across the plains desert all
that Mongols yeah we would kill the
Mongols we would also cross over Russia
into Alaska yeah visit our Inuit friends
yeah back before that closed all you
might say you went in none of it I did
go to Nunavut and you're around real
Inuits yeah that's right we shot a film
up in the Arctic Circle in yeah Nunavut
to Canada it is the it's the Inuit
territory yeah and things are different
up there you didn't eat any raw because
your [ __ ] no I ate a little bit of raw
meat no I ate a little bit of caribou
some are caribou I was invited on a
polar bear hunt you didn't go did not go
yeah I wouldn't know there's many sad to
shoot a polar bear well you know the
thing is it's 20 there's they give away
in Nunavut the agreement is they give
away 20 contracts you know the
government in association with the
elders and this and that and they've
decided that 20 polar bear because you
can't really just relegate an entire
people up to here go up there and we're
just gonna start this whole thing down
here in North America and by the way
don't eat those animals because we think
they're cute yeah and there's and
there's four of them left that's right
because they're gonna be like well we're
gonna eat them anyway until they're gone
and then so 20 they got 20 contract for
20 and Iqaluit is the capital of Nunavut
and 10 of those contracts go to a
Calumet and so we so well and so yeah
anyway so one of the guys one of our
drivers Luke pick he had a friend who
got a contract and he said would you
like to come
pull the bear hunting with us I said no
no as I was already foreseeing that now
I don't think anyone would give a [ __ ]
because I'm just me but
I was all ready for seeing that like
Chris Pratt over a fallen lion no
showing the internet something like
that's bad press it's bad press
now imagine like you kill them that's
not flight I don't want to be around for
a polar bear getting shot meaning and I
don't think any white guys should it's
like it's their thing at the end of the
way they're doing it do it okay fine
it's not the lights it's not not for was
not for why not for whites not for
whites not for what yes for the Inuit
yes for the Inuit not for whites yes for
the Inuit not for whites yes for the
whole mmm [ __ ] man that's them do you
know how the Inuit used to kill polar
bear cuz they did this is they were a
rough group oh yes they would kill Polly
Browne now do you for 10 points do you
know how they used to kill polar bear
okay Spears Spears and and but what
would they do would they would they
surround the polar bear yes good luck no
they didn't oh you're not [ __ ] coming
up to a polar bear with your [ __ ]
dumb spear you're just gonna piss it off
and it's gonna go really what I think
but haven't I seen some Inuit art with
pounding because the Inuit are
well-known [ __ ] liar
hey man artistic liar okay I'm sitting
here representing my own wit people of
Camden study assassination take those
are not liars on their heart each pick
is not a liar hearts are very black with
sin and lies I'm just saying the truth
just telling you oh my goodness tell you
what the Discovery Channel they found
that I don't give a [ __ ] what the
Discovery Channel says I'm gonna get the
Government of Canada hearts I mean a
just and true their heart oh they did a
study their hearts are made of if you
would eat a piece of Inuit heart it
would taste like I immediately cuz no
ice and it's poison oh my goodness
that's terrible I know it is what a
horrible thing I know in fact you can
take a you can take an Inuit heart and
put it out on the ice and animals from
everywhere well they're a hundred miles
will stay away they will stay away from
you I'm just telling about the discovery
i don't discover they're very nice
people but in the a very nice people are
there library there are very traditional
people they're very welcoming and warm
people and i just i don't believe what
you say I'm just
kill polar bears I'm glad I love him
people do this they go I believe that
they're welcoming I believe that they're
good people but I'm just telling you yet
their hearts yeah we'll keep animals
away for a hundred miles
yes so what is that I don't disagree
that they are the salt of the earth just
wonderful people that you know just
absolutely some of the sweetest people
yeah well I hate I and I and I'm not
saying they're not I'm saying that
they're inherently very bad people what
I'm saying is two things
yeah and you can say two things this is
like your Harold Harold goes my buddy
goes but when I take fish oil my skin is
better and he goes I'm sure it is but
I'm telling you fish oil is poisonous
like some kids might end the
conversation yeah they'll just say I'm
sure that's true that that all races to
you are equal but I'm saying they're not
yeah yeah like wait what do I say like
what a minute what are you here to say
that that's the dumbest high school
debate team good way to say I'm sure
that everything you're saying is true
but it isn't yeah but it isn't the Inuit
would wait till the polar bear was
sleeping oh and the thing would be
asleep and I guess they'd sleep summer
and then you'd come in there and stab
the [ __ ] out of it with your with your
Spears smart and typically the bone of
the polar bear is very very hard so they
would use the polar bear bone and
sharpen that [ __ ] down and that's what
they would stab seals in their faces
with when the girls when they came up
for air you wait fillet commentary yeah
and you go hey hey that's a horrible
joke man it is it's a lard way to live
yeah you're just eating nothing but
protein there's no vegetation out there
frozen fish frozen fish so they'd cook
fish I guess but it gots but you need
seal oil or whale oil
you got a blubber the fat by the way if
you didn't get a seal that that winter
you basically lived in the dark you
lived in the [ __ ] dark and you're
eating yeah and you got no fire no or
you just go to Popeyes and get some
chicken issues no um
the they eat everything like raw they
enjoy eating it raw and they need
everything walrus skin yep
yeah well Sam my buddy Sam sure and when
studied him and he had wolf mittens wolf
fur mittens
that came up to your like elbow and they
had never been cured it was just they
took the fur off and because it's so
cold it just basically you leave them
outside and you can wear those mittens
unbelievable yeah it was really really
something to really something to behold
that movie will come out soon it's going
Grizzlies oh yeah yeah anyway what else
is going on where's Brendan yeah he is
in New York doing something for Showtime
sweet yeah it's great he's interviewing
I think down top Wow the weirdest leg
cramp just that these little chairs man
all right bro these little [ __ ]
chairs right though you know Brendan
fits and I'm just taking yeah Brendan's
a big guy but Brendan's not you know
Brendan is is uh he's V doubt yeah you
know he's he's got the [ __ ] shape in
all the right places yeah it does have a
bubble ass yeah right but he's got mine
but he's got narrow man hips and [ __ ]
and he's got those glutes that [ __ ]
yeah come together and just press his
[ __ ] no room for his balls all right
just saying Brendan's got a nice [ __ ]
set everything all right and he I'm sure
he fits fine and I see that the show or
pictures of you guys on the you know on
the sets like everyone looks so
comfortable and then I come here and
it's like I'm sitting in coach doing a
podcast can't you can't fly coach no I
can't fly coach you fly first-class I
fly I fly cockpit all right I just go in
and I sit in the corner of the cockpit
and they can't get yeah I'm good don't
worry about me I'm not gonna cause any
trouble yeah yeah and they go yeah just
sit there on the ground like a [ __ ]
giant teddy you still got your Bull
heart cast yeah I still got huge guess
so what's he's in New York he's
interviewing Deontay Wilder I think now
I don't follow the fight game is he's a
heavyweight boxer the best American
heavyweight probably oh that's awesome
yeah with a bring bring down tail while
they're up take a look at his body if
you want to talk about you want their
two men might be the the best bodies
that you can have one would be one is
interviewing the guy and the other
interview the other is is that guy she's
yeah you don't get better-looking or
more symmetrical Dean than Dante right
calm down
Brian I mean that's it that's a yeah oh
that's a that's a beautiful human being
yeah yeah he's simply a he's simply a
nubian warrior that last picture we just
saw we're close behind that body I was
just never I'd walk around like what's
up look at this looks okay agile as he
beats the [ __ ] out of people
he should [ __ ] like he should we need
him to [ __ ] everybody because that
that's just a he's just a she's gonna
say he's gonna save them I would I would
present him with my wife yeah I would
present him I would I would say sir you
are the alpha man I present you and
present you with my wife I would dollar
up yeah I doll her up and I'd go there
you go yeah go yeah you go and do tape
it and watch it periodically I would I
would he would he would give me a child
I would have the child would be mine and
hopefully it would be a son I would
raise it to be a great warrior
yeah and and I and he I guess I don't
know if he'd be in the child's life I
did he'd be uncle Deonte be our secret
right obviously our secret but he would
look exactly like him well with my my
wife's was your wife's caller antics in
his color his genius
yeah the Viking and the end the that's a
new useful should always be breathing we
need that's why we would take our wooly
moose yeah we would drape them in the
finest silks and Velvets yes and we
would take our maidens yes and your
maids
yes and we would put them in the antlers
of the woolly me yes I don't know if
this is anybody we would just walk them
we would just walk them right into
Africa right and we would be like ego
ego ego ego ego yeah I would whatever
bad moriata Klee and I would cry I would
I would cry and hit myself useful haha
and I would and then I'd be mean to my
wife because I would feel inadequate and
it would tear our family as Islander but
I'd have a [ __ ] great kid yeah you'd
also have a huge hard-on because it
would turn you on yeah because I got
problems
yeah yes it would it would it there'd be
a deep perversion yeah that people would
see that lives in my heart
yeah they're just to be outclassed it's
called sperm competition that's what
it's called a Discovery Channel did
thing on that day did not yeah where you
see another man in
there and apparently your penis is
shaped with the hood so you get the
other sperm out and you get your sperm
in yeah that's that theory yeah and I I
subscribe to it wholeheartedly
do you ever just go into your backyard
and snap off a twig or branch put it
into your piss hole and beat off bro
that's not a question I think is
appropriate it's no rules answer is of
course not so did you now did you know
that recently yeah I'm not sure if you
knew this uh-huh Floyd Mayweather
Mayweather jr. yeah fought Conor
McGregor Conor McGregor yeah this bait
just happened okay like last weekend all
right now W now perhaps some of your
listeners yeah would like to hear about
your thoughts on the fight nope because
we've covered this ad nauseam and you
are not qualified to talk about it oh
you know what already let me tell you I
sure am NOT yeah because I watched the
fight yeah I know I everyone talked so
much about the fight I particularly took
in a lot of what you guys had to say
about it I was really fascinated by what
Brendan had to say about and like it's
just his outlying opinion of which was
in my opinion you know proven the guy
you know he [ __ ] hung out he [ __ ]
hung out yeah the guy I mean I was you
know I was for Conor I was like I think
he's gonna do it and then everyone
watches it and then you know I'm up with
my buddies in Canada and then it's over
and then everybody has an opinion of
course and that's annoying what's what
makes voice so good shut up yeah it's
over everybody wants now it's over yeah
oh yeah I knew it you know I mean a dad
boxer that guy he's 50 you know he was
like the great food I'd like sit there
listening my buddies go a couple of them
are probably listening right now my
talent Marc listens to every show hey
Marc actually mark wasn't over and our
other pal Jamie's watching the fight so
Marc is absolved of this yeah yeah of
course you want oh yeah everybody's got
never been punched you know everybody's
got a point of view yeah but what makes
for it so good is that he fought him in
a way that he's never fought anybody
if he had wanted to sit on his back foot
and get out of the way and make Connor
missed all the time
the way he did to everybody like Canelo
and to Manny Pacquiao Connor obviously
would have had a very hard time even
laying a glove on him but he didn't want
that press and he goes you know what I'm
gonna stand in your grille I'm gonna
keep my weight on my front foot I'm
gonna fight you the way I'm gonna so I'm
just gonna I'm gonna so I'm gonna walk
you down and is that what happened yes
and then you know he's winking at his
dad in the corner but Connor you know he
got to give kind of credit because when
Boyd sat there and fought him Connor put
his hands on his face
yeah but Connor a bit Floyd said look
you guys know if I wanted to box him the
way I box people it would have been a
very different event interesting but
he's so good that he can change his
style essentially and go alright let me
see your power you're a bigger man I got
you you throw it throw all your stuff at
me yeah it's tough and now I know I'm
gonna just knock you out there's a rumor
that he put 400 grand on himself to take
Connor out in the 10th round which I
could believe because he's that good I
can believe that
what makes guys like that so good is
they can download your whole game plan
that's so you can just download
everything you're doing that's the
difference between you and me you know
all this stuff and it's great and I
download everything I do and I've
watched wrestling some jams like seven
yeah which is also it's also fight
already [ __ ] you already here in a fade
[ __ ] you I say to you cuz I got no
respect but keep going well I don't know
anything about actually wrestling I
don't know I'm just saying I watch it
now or boxing yeah but you or my feet
yeah but you jump around you jump around
in a gym right I'll say jump around you
jump around in a gym jump I'm yeah if I
catch angle no no no you put on house of
pain and you jump around and you jump
around in there and [ __ ] you and Tony
right way Michalek the great way Mac
alright so you jump around and he
pretend throws you know the focus pads
and you're like remember this dude do it
like this have it bad pet hit a pet pet
pet pet like a three-year-old would just
go you know when girls teach each other
pad no that's not what it's like that's
what no it's exactly what it looks like
Wow no now let's play pattycake when I
turn a bit bit
I tell my plan today over when I sit
down and my punches yeah when I sit down
ever hear a gun go off yes
bang bang bang yeah that's not what your
punches on who who's shooting the
machine gun they say that's what I'm
just saying is off in the distance you
know here when they're when they're
behind the closed door of my gym right
and I'm working yeah and I'm putting in
work as we say in the light game yeah
but then you but you shouldn't say that
but well that's what they say you don't
deserve to say that and I'm just saying
that but when I put in work yeah they go
I got a funny story about this they go
who's shooting the machine gun by the
way what what I love about boxing and
when you're an actor like me and you're
50 and you you're right hop around the
ring and maybe I spar with headgear with
the guy who's really never boxed before
and I still get hit and and you know
maybe I get the best of him because he
hasn't been doing it this long or maybe
he's just not very athletic what'll
happen is you you will trainers when
they're talking to somebody else in
front of you you know what they'll say
it's great and of course they know
better and they'll say they'll sake to
make you feel good and look good though
bro this guy's got skills he can box oh
and of course I of course I can't of
course I can and and and I know what
they're doing right but it's very common
for them to give you props even if you
suck right and it's almost like if
they're I don't know what it is but
there's almost a thing for that in that
bro he's got skills he can move around
well of course they're keeping it
positive they're keeping their own the
gym put me at one time with a guy and a
good amateur and I get knocked out I
don't know about that I don't know about
that but I will tell you this for all
the things you know about boxing and
like I said you hop and skip around a
gym and you hip a bit bit bit bit yeah a
bit yeah a bit yeah
I don't know anything about the actual
act of professional wrestling or how any
of it works you know what I mean
physically I don't know I just watch it
on TV you know I'm kind of a fan I've
always been a fan but I tell you what if
I had Arn Anderson and Tully Blanchard
holding you out at the wrists and ankles
and I came off the second rope with my
knee and drove it right into your shin
your leg would break okay and then I
would wear a t-shirt that says I broke
Bryan Callens leg and I would also like
to say
that if there are any listeners of the
aforementioned 10-minute podcast and the
fighter and the kid who listen to both
shows and appreciate both shows Perth
shows well when we're talking about
fighting the kids bro shows yeah I would
like for you to please please photoshop
a picture of me wearing a t-shirt that
says I broke Brian Allen's leg I don't
need you going out to boran's
or because I'm gonna tell you or you can
make a Photoshop a Brian wearing a
t-shirt that says will sasso Brooklyn
yeah but see excuse me and know you guys
are gonna share it all over the Internet
something friends with Coburg yeah yeah
Bill Goldberg one of his mattify man I
just had to run he won the universal
title he's my god you don't know any of
this stuff you had him on the show you
don't know what the heck to ask him
okay well all okay you know take it easy
because not Brent but Brendan Brendan
does because also Bill Goldberg is a fan
the fight game yeah he loves a more time
like that
Muay Thai trains have been training for
years yeah you'll beat the [ __ ] out of
most people he will be between you well
okay I'm not gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
you're talking to me okay well literally
while ordering food you hey man that's
very disrespectful you know that right
don't whistle when you talk to me listen
oh man we're not gonna get into that
won't have a nice time today all right
stop whistling right now I will get
upset you will catch things in the face
there's lights and there's pictures and
this my water is large and the table is
heavy [ __ ] that water is so stupid
watch it's literally the biggest thing
you can use that as a weapon or as a
doorstop or as like okay listen this is
what that you can use that water for you
don't want a spaceship when the door is
gonna closed because they have to seal
it and because the aliens coming from
you you're gonna be locked in you're
gonna die I could I like and it's hot
it's [ __ ] like it's a steel door yeah
I could put that in front of that steel
door I'd be able to squeeze through this
would be yeah this would be the stars of
the movie like it holds the door open
yeah yeah bill Gold Bill Goldberg has a
gray goatee
which may lure you
and go oh he's got a silver beard but
he's older he's he's older he's you guys
probably around the same age maybe 50 50
brilliantly oh wow okay both v um half a
century but then he takes his shirt off
right and then it's a different thing
he's an athlete I would love nothing
more than for guys who have made their
name as professional wrestling and
certainly bill Goldberg's you know done
all sorts of things and you know hosted
television done many things with his
career but I like I would love for guys
who have made their name in sports
entertainment or whatever you want to
call it to just go out and beat people
up like like it used to be in the 70s
yeah you know just beat you up when
Tully Blanchard Noren Anderson would
spread bryan callen out by the wrists
and ankles and i'm gonna jump off the
second rope with i me now i'm put it
right michelle and break now your shin
take your bones and go go seal hunting
with your bones seal hunting with bryan
Callens bones no oh would you if you
ever no heaven forbid had to lose an
appendage yeah would you let me have the
bones I I so I could make a necklace
[ __ ] you no no [ __ ] you but no what
would that be
now listen if you lost your foot like
let's say always like hey I go to my
doctor I'm like do I straight-up have
like so much diabetes you know what's a
woman would you rather lose from the
knee down or from the elbow down uh-oh
for me it's knee down with respect to
everybody who has had to make that
decision
you know actually nobody's ever had to
make that decision damn respect people
have had one or the other or both well
cuz I know I know some guys in veterans
I'm sure you do Nate who've lost Nate
was a marine for seven years - shut the
[ __ ] up all right he's over there all
quiet but but you shut the [ __ ] you very
much eh I appreciate it I do appreciate
what your dog what you put your company
he's over here like just like that like
the sweetest pit bull Yeah right got
alarms on him yeah yeah it does come on
here come over again on the Microsoft
lion
Brian man cuz tres Collins got something
say now this guy could choke me out yeah
in in about three
Yeah right he's a green water tinsel yes
he's a looker to us of course he is me
to train my dogs and my wife and my
daughter yeah my wife my daughter got
all bright-eyed and bushy-tailed yeah so
I had to discipline both of them they
were both sent to their room I'm sure
they were really hapless and then there
are pictures of him and and all my
wife's friends were like well I want him
to train my dog yeah you know what I
mean yeah I know what you mean then I
had to I had to make a rumor I notice
there's no wedding ring I had to say no
he's got a girl but he's no no wedding
ring okay so that's enough for but but
I'm saying the pictures that are sent to
Amanda's friends they see no whoa that's
right and they're just like oh I would
like for him to come over and train my
dogs right I'm doing air quotes
yep for those of you using trained my
dog yep tramadol something must
something that's right that's right I
discipline me and teach me how to be
well anyway or to mum there's a lot of
discipline that's involved in the dog
training community as well for sure
they're Israel but contrary to the
popular belief it's not about making a
submissive dog which I was trying to
tell people it's about confidence like
when you came in here confidence was
through the roof thank you people see me
roll into a room and bang things with my
knee and they go sit down shut up sit
down dummy
sit down he knows I come in here I
almost knocked everybody over yeah you
know with the setup and everything's
very you you know with this kind of
electrical it with this kind of
equipment you can't be knocking [ __ ]
over I know it all the time with my
stuff and I'm banging my knees off of
things and it's up yeah confident yeah
they'll teach you how to like he'll
teach a dog how to bark but not bite and
and look fiercest [ __ ] tell us how you
do that with a dog it's pretty
fascinating like Aris teaching a dog how
to be just just get a dog if I want a
dog to just look really mean and barked
up a storm when it not might not bite
when an intruder comes in tell us how
you do that so like an alert command
right yeah so everything when it comes
to working with the dog though is
showing them the behavior you want them
to perform and then giving them some
sort of value back to that behavior yeah
so with the dog if somebody wants a dog
to show a strong appearance and that
deterrent factor then what you do is you
basically show the dog that
when they become confident the bad guy
goes away so we'll have somebody come
around the side and the dogs you know on
a leash so he can't go attack the person
because that would be bad and you put up
this strong front and the second the dog
barks you act like that bark is like a
super bark from the movie bolt so the
dog barks and you're like oh like you
just were hit by that bark and the dog
goes holy crap I could bark you away
from me and the more you do it the
higher their confidence comes and then
we want to put on a command we tell the
owner we say hey well you're gonna say
is whatever you want your command to be
so you want to be easy or alert or
whatever they say you're not telling the
dog the [ __ ] peace that would be my
command well easy is good because you
could play the role like I was telling
the dog easy easy
relax buddy right so when they say easy
then you come out as the bad guy dog
barks at you after enough of those it
becomes a pattern that the dog
recognizes and when the owner says easy
dog goes bad guys coming in starts
barking right and then that's when the
cops come around later they say everyone
was he was telling the dog easy easy
right it's not his fault that's it and
the cops are like oh wow this guy's
laying here like a bunch of taco meat
and it's not you know maids fault he was
saying easy easy
then they take the dog away those are
perfect for dogs when you don't want
them to bite okay right it's just that
deterrent cuz most people see that
vicious dog party barking not gonna know
Brian starts part and he's like on this
on that and I fight and I box a pit and
we go oh oh oh Brian you're so strong oh
and Brendan's like I'm a [ __ ]
world-class fighter but I'm a 50 year
old friend Bob Brian and hopping around
a gym oh yeah but here's the thing
weapons of opportunity though yeah I
already notice that about you that's
what they talk about in the Marine Corps
weapons of opportunity yeah you're
talking about yeah
the subscriber walks in he walks in he's
got his weapons everything is a weapon
if I'm looking I'm looking around look
I'm okay so I'm a big guy can handle
myself you know I can just I can run
into people and mash them against walls
I can hug them too tight and dry
another thing is I'm wiry if it's not
nailed down you're catching it in the
[ __ ] head oh you better watch out if
you got like a big rotor on the kind of
things that are in a room in 2007 he had
a rotary phone
nothing fax machine a turntable hood
turntable [ __ ] like that a cannon yeah
cannon a big mixer big electric mixer
reaching Kyoto [ __ ] a nice box any of
these things that would be in a room a
Geiger counter an abacus if you I know
Nate's got his own show on discount on
Animal Planet called from rescue dogs
super dog what's the name of your if
people like what's the name of your dog
training company why live here's Legacy
Foundation which is a non-profit here is
Legacy Foundation yes not broth named
after my dog if I okay so if I wanted to
he's got melon waz bite you in the
[ __ ] I saw you about a month or so
ago at the TCA event okay oh he was
walking around I want to say hi but I'm
like I don't want to be that guy who
comes over and you know I'm sure you get
enough people coming up nobody know
people do they just don't want to say
things they don't want to be bad come on
now oh you were great in the eighties
you're wearing you know the you know
what I was there for the TCAs Loudermilk
coming to the audience Network and
DirecTV now on October 17 louder louder
milk with Ron Livingston and Will Sasso
that's right it's Loudermilk October
17th or 18th walk going on 17th
Loudermilk on the AT&T s audience
Network and if you miss it it's their
banner network if you miss they Joe oh
well they black nope they bought DirecTV
if you miss a role now is it not
anything else
hey you know there's a guy named Ron
Livingston who's about the height age
weight and look of Bryan Callen way more
talented these was Will Sasso a
Loudermilk yeah thanks for the
advertisement that's great if I if I if
I gave you a million dollars and I said
Nate and I'm being serious with this
question I have this Malinois I want to
be able to have it now more will
Malinois chocolate cookie with dutch
chocolate to Dutch shepherds at the
marshmallow chocolate
Sadat Shepherd is that a misspelled more
oh yeah Lamar oh us how would you train
a dog to bite somebody somewhere
specific
lion-o is not oh you could you train a
dog too but have them bite somewhere
somebody somewhere specific yeah well if
you gave me a million dollars a train
the most perfect dog for you I would
hire better trainers than me and then I
would keep that's good all right
but yeah incredible dog beautiful and
you know when you guys were talking
about what part of the leg or arm or
whatever there was uh actually somebody
on the show rescue dog - Superdog where
she had a rock-climbing accident she
fell from about 40 feet and lost one of
her legs and so we trained a dog for her
to turn on and off the light switch to
retrieve items for her it was really
cool the dog would actually run down the
hallway and press the elevator button
for her because she had this long
hallway
and she had the accident before or after
she all right but the dog to do that
well it's you know like anything else
you break it down to the smallest pieces
and he put it together for the final
product so I just taught the dog to
target a sticky pad so every time he
touched the sticky pad I rewarded him
for that and then I moved the sticky pad
closer and closer to the light switch or
the elevator button yeah and then
eventually the sticky pads gone but the
dog still does the behavior hoping for a
reward and this little guy would come
cruising around the corner jump up and
hit that elevator button I was adorable
so I get if I show if I showed a dog a
picture of wills nub because he's got a
nub I got a little a little nub and
maybe I got a smell yeah oh yeah oh yeah
it smells bad and it looks like a little
like it looks like Mike I never see like
chicken gizzards in the in the yeah in
the gross yeah and there's like a big
pack of them flat $2.50 perfect just
grab one of them out throw it away that
little [ __ ] yeah that's kind of like
what might not work you discolored and
just reward all the time in here every
time he comes close and then he bites
you in the dome now all right well thank
you Nate but I got a heavy bag
definitely should I all right that is a
beautiful dog they're incredible they're
they're really really driven dogs but
they're definitely not for an
inexperienced dog owner you need not for
a family either need experience or you
need to be working with somebody who's
experienced because sorry I was saying
you sooner or later you're gonna have
our friend Katie Mixon on the show yeah
yeah you gotta have Katie Mixon who's
American housewife was her show on ABC
and I'm buddies with her and her husband
bro Grier who's former Olympian we were
talking about him on the show but I
there's a dog that they have they have a
couple these dogs what can you tell us
about this because I was they have a
hundred and ninety pound Presa Canario
and then another one that's like a
hundred and seven scare me these are
just terrifying to be around
sweetie-pies
and until they kill you I mean well
they're lying hunting dogs right well
Presa Canario has I think I believe are
basically a combination of a mastiff and
they're powerful dogs and there are
people that actually train these dogs
for some of the protection sports out
there and this would be considered an
off breed for the sport you know most
people use the German Shepherd of the
mountain or the Dutch Shepherd but I
have seen people work with these dogs
and use them for whoa competitive
obedience and training protection
training to focus my they are powerful
definitely now could you train here's
what I'm getting at could you train more
presa canarios to take the place of
let's say the you know put them in the
sort of modify the wheel wells of
smaller car like a Fiat or smart car
with one chair in the middle because
again we don't like these coach seats no
with it like a nice like a nice throne
maybe some regal looking leather and
wood like a headboard at home regal big
comfy chair for me to just go around my
neighborhood go grocery shopping with
for presa canarios sort of like and they
just walk next to you know they know
they carry the cab of this yeah smart
car that's a pack and that's a dangerous
I that is afraid of I love I've had pit
bulls my whole life possibly paw I'm
afraid of a dog that big because I don't
know how I would control 160 look look
at that look at the picture of the press
canario fighting the bear
well let's not see that over on the far
right ain't real it's totally real peril
kill a bus over to there I'll eat
oppressed look at that that's a real
picture someone should someone should
photoshop kotti shirt onto that bear
that says I broke Bryan County leg No
that's not true someone we you know I
Photoshop a t-shirt onto that bear that
says now I broke Brian Collins like no
could you somehow put this picture out
to the people anyway it's the only
picture of a bear fighting a Presa
Canario on the internet the press
canarios got a chain around its neck
that's Brian no and then the bear
swatting it I have a I do stand up to
larger yeah animals and I will fight you
you stand up comedy for larger what do
you think a press canary has that's a
dangerous I mean not they're very
friendly dogs but I just worry about I
worry about the specific breeds that
don't that that where you don't know
who's been breeding them and they're
kind of still a rare dog so you're out
there's always that unpredictable factor
like not in the dog the dogs are
friendly yeah you can train her to bite
the [ __ ] out of people but for the most
part I just they're so powerful yeah I
worry about a dog like yeah dog like
that I would basically do a lot of fun
obedience with that dog I want
everything to be fun enjoyable
entertaining I wouldn't want to you know
a lot of times when you have a dog
people have come up to me and they said
hey can you do this protection training
for my dog it's like well you really
don't need that because a dog a lot of
times as a deterrent and you don't want
to be put in a position where you have
this liability now don't go somewhere
and you know someone goes and pets a dog
because everybody does that we have a
dog out in the in town someone goes in
pets a you're not watching you're
talking on the phone or whatever now you
have this this problem so you know a lot
of times something like that I want to
have fun with that dog and show them
that the world is a pleasant awesome
place and nobody's gonna mess with the
dog that big anyway yeah that's true you
know if you know what if you come to
somebody's house where as a press canary
oh yeah you have a machine yeah yeah now
you'd go the other way they said that
this guy said look if a guy's gonna come
through your barking dog and you have a
big Shepherd you have a pressing are you
he has a gun he's in there to kill you
right and he's professionally you better
have you better be waiting on the other
side of that door guy talking about that
here's something really interesting one
of my previous landlords her husband
used to do photography I don't know what
the terminology for this would be but he
would take photos of homicide scenes Oh
los angeles and every single scene that
he had been to they never owned a dog so
a dog was like an incredibly huge
deterrent because most people if they're
going to rob a place they want to get in
when no one's there
we want and leave and most people like
dogs I wouldn't say they don't want I
love french bulldog puppies they look
like babies French bulldogs are adorable
little french bulldog keep me from
getting murdered in the night well you
may know I mean my partner know that
dogs can be incredibly adorable right
nobody's gonna want to hurt that dog
they're gonna go to the next house my
German Shepherd I grabbed my daughter
and she screamed I was I was tickling
her my German Shepherd bit me on the
calf she she just went Boop and I went
whoa she goes hey stop that way well she
got I think you felt lean also
protecting she was at like that and I
went oh she it was like a warning it was
really interesting
no probably could we create an
oppressive scenario to have a cute
little we train a big press Canario to
have a cute little French Bulldog barked
so that would be a Laura man you may
lure in the criminals so that they can
tear him to shreds yeah you could you'd
be surprised what you can teach that
makes me think one of my friends she has
a Malinois and she taught the dog to
whisper so she would say whisper and the
dog would basically whisper back it'd be
a very soft how the [ __ ] do you do that
you gotta ask her well I mean it's it's
rewarding behaviors that the dogs do
maybe naturally right so you teach the
dogs raises for example right you're
gonna reward them goodies and then after
a while I start to associate sneeze with
reward with innocence
I wouldn't say good sneeze though I
would use whatever the dog's marker is
so like a yes or clicker or something
like that so the moment the dog does
that sound she marked it and continue to
do it until it became a behavior that
the dog offered up and then she just
named Cesar Millan so he used to train
he had to train the people first it's
always people yeah definitely it's not
the dog it's always a lot of times the
dogs can figure it out pretty quickly
you take somebody who's an incredible
dog handler and they can make a dog
that's not so well trained look
phenomenal and you can take somebody who
knows nothing about handling a dog and
it's gonna make a dog who's well trained
look like it's poorly trained well so a
lot of times it is more important to
know what to do I tell people all the
time dog trainings not easy
or rather dog trainings not difficult
once you know what you're supposed to do
and a lot of times I'm afraid people are
gonna figure out how easy it is and I'm
not gonna have a job anymore
thank God we don't need to hire a dog
trainer this is that so it's subtle yeah
you need it because there's [ __ ] like
Brian who don't know what to do
don't say that so you might have iced
really knew a lot about dog training
when we first started working together
Lee I was do some reading nope dude are
you gonna drop some knowledge about dogs
nope had dogs my whole [ __ ] life
Oh training ABARES I think on your
podcast before talking about clicker
training with a bear yes not translator
yeah big teddy bear
yeah no no no swatting knows what no
swatting no either you have to hit them
when they of the Train where or they
take them brats when they when they
start to pour their nub you don't let
them they father nub yeah they try to
eat their own poop
hold up there in the Arctic so every
once in a while polar bears got to eat a
nice big handful of [ __ ] and go to sleep
that's right so those Inuit can sneak up
on it and stab it in the face with its
own bones that's why I've been stomping
homosapiens we take what we want and
we'll eat your flesh most bears are not
like will though and we'll let you
correct them ya know you don't ya that's
what you do not tell a bear what to do
right you reward their behavior and as
they're moving in that direction you say
good job and so they start to mark good
behavior your commands with with getting
a reward don't start - so you go out you
don't go a no and hit them in the face
although there was that guy who got in
trouble
training chimpanzees he was training
there was she you wouldn't hotel bear
with no you wouldn't
nicely he would but with she bones he's
the simple don't say like that bring up
up bring up a hairless chimpanzee please
just say show people champ or chimpanzee
French and so so you see me on secret
crypto lab ah look at that take a look
at there yeah just just click on that
and then just keep going that these are
chimps that had allergies they're full
grown animals now take a look at the
on that back it looks like the
Emelianenko brothers dad or something
that actually looks like my dad my
sweetheart dad he looks your [ __ ]
head off you're literally off your body
this trainer said this woman in San
Diego Zoo I showed her that she goes
yeah he'll pull your head off here your
body look at that look at that look at
how close set those shoulders are and
good luck good luck when he brings you
close yeah yeah that's why you never put
yourself in that situation why does he
he's got the balls and dick like me he's
got the little chicken gizzard yeah they
don't they don't have dicks they have no
dead but he's built for cruelty they're
built yeah cruelty and to break and pull
things apart um that's our close
ancestor yep and what what what this guy
was doing he was training the chimps and
he was punching him in the face for real
and they were like dude and he goes look
these things are like bam bam this is
how I trained him there's got to be a
better way to train a chimp he got a big
trouble for it he was a trainer for
Hawley I'm gonna stick with dogs yeah I
know them I like them the great if
you've been I've been on a set where
they had full-grown champs we donate you
you are a mechanic for semi trucks and
Class C vehicles what do you think of
this submarine I don't yeah but we
punched it and the vital just don't do
it I don't know I got to work on these
trucks will do you talking about hey
check out the submarine here you want to
get inside it and [ __ ] around
no it'll blow up or slam into something
or go way down in the ocean or [ __ ]
chesil explode what are you talking
about well I know a guy who punched it
yeah that's well you're right stick to
stick to stick to what you know yes you
know about shim Fonzie's well I mean you
or at least having a good comparison
though as far as utilizing positive
reinforcement though to teach somebody
to do something that you want repeated
right see here saying so that was a good
comparison and because we were talking
about bears as well you can't use any
sort of Corrections to get a bear to do
something because he's just gonna throw
you across the room that's right you
have to get him to want to do the
behaviors by rewarding with positive
reinforcement and that would be the same
with that I would not want one of those
angry with me not not by any one sweet
fish
I always keep them happy with good tweet
fashion good boy
should you have a dog now though no I
don't have a dog now oh you gotta guess
I get yourself that little Frenchie I'll
train it for you really love a
friendship gonna be amazing
they're such cute dogs yeah one of my
last mermaids out of Frenchie and the
dog was adorable
plus you can even do if you want you can
do bite work with a Frenchie you can
they love it they love the toys no no no
no no that's bad so when he takes his
paws to his nub like that I gotta say no
good job now now I mastered No hey now
match your bait together
good boy
look he's repeating the behavior this no
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] bear Millie
Brian friends bears to thumb their
[ __ ] and jerk off and he gives us a
swedish fish right it's the most [ __ ]
up thing so they say to you hey wait
about this guy's punching chimpanzees
just gauging how [ __ ] up you like it
hey come over to my place
check out my garage Nate doing that holy
[ __ ] you have a beard no it's cool man
that's cool I give him swedish fish and
he thumbs his [ __ ] and jerks off for
us my wife and kids love it just make
sure you don't run out of Sweden I gotta
get him him just move his balls around a
little bit
[Music]
die you [ __ ] die you [ __ ] barrel
get another 100 hours of bizarre
yeah was weird let's take a break I got
a pay back from our piss break I was
just talking about how I saw Hamilton
last night and it's it's oh that's nice
yeah it's a [ __ ] masterpiece it
really is and I define him I guess a
masterpiece in the sense that when
you've been in the business for a long
time and then you see a work of art or
like a sort of somebody do something and
you go I don't know how you did that
like I don't even know I can't even
conceive how you could have put a story
together and songs like that together on
that level and there were probably 36
songs I mean I don't know how it was two
hours three hours
yeah and the dancing was singing I'm not
a big musical theater guy and really
yeah right but I could watch that all
day long it was just it was just it's a
national treasure man yeah swear to God
I got it I got to see it I have not seen
it and yeah during Brian's piss break he
made me come with him into the bathroom
and told me about it yeah and and yeah
you were saying you went by yourself
which is how I prefer to go to like
concerts and stuff anyway yeah my
daughter but they sat they had to sit
because tickets are so hard well I had I
sat alone and we sat together right
there you go there you go but hey
there's talking about sitting alone in
the theater that that is I like you can
have your own private experience well I
was saying during the break I was also
saying that with it last time I was in
New York my good pal Christian
Montopolis from you know also yeah
played moan that's Three Stooges he
plays Russ in Silicon Valley he's an
incredible actor and a chameleon he did
a he did a stint on he Beebe's the
romantic lead of waitress the musical on
Broadway that was written all the music
was written by Sara Bareilles who's a
you know music star pop star in her own
right and she did a ten week stint also
playing the female lead so I went to the
show by myself in New York and yeah it
was incredible and I'm sitting by myself
and there was this nice couple to my
left and on my right was this mom and
two daughters and everyone was there to
see Sara Bareilles cuz it's these you
know these people big fans first and my
mum
maybe my dad might have cried oh dude
hey I [ __ ] cry and fear I cry and I'm
alone and I'm crying because it's it's
that good and that glorious and I and
you know what I cry about I go like this
I swear to God I go I go oh I go that's
what human beings are capable of in
between under favorable circle it's
interesting that we have bility to sing
and singing is you're getting really
emotional and almost I almost cried that
might occur I might cry a lot but my
moon when Moomin
you have Sarah paralysis did it did that
go goes she was she was she sang her
beautiful excuse me I love when I was
singing very beautiful songs and she
goes she's a really good sheriff yeah I
might have got misty yeah it was good
yeah yeah I got that I'm gonna go again
I don't like bad crying acting crime
there you go I'm for me your kids will
do that yeah I mean I'm like your fake
crying and it's annoying me even though
I love you as my child you're annoying
me right now but like and just like Nate
would train a dog yeah wouldn't you do
some laughter training then to say
you're [ __ ] around without saying
[ __ ] don't say it suck
hey you [ __ ] pay they're in the wrong
world right that's right and when you
say hey hey stop [ __ ] around you're
not actually crying they start giggling
and laughing they do wills there I'm the
fun uncle I make them laugh yep I
believe in humor for all circumstances
that drives my wife crazy but for me
yeah I believe in humor for [ __ ]
everything Brian if I can say something
about my friend Brian
yeah that's true yeah you would I think
there's room for humor know if you're on
fire yeah there's there's room for humor
my buddy did you ever write a book
that's what it should be my buddy Dave
Utley who has to have a very very
dangerous operation he's got he had
spinal bifida so he doesn't have a neck
and he has he has a hunchback and he's
you know it's a hard life for him right
now and his spine is crushing his lungs
yes so he's in pain all the time and he
gets shingles and you know it's you have
an hour time but funny as [ __ ] comic
yeah always positive yeah and I can
never help but to just say things that
like I don't know like oh did you ever
think that maybe you're this way because
you're a sinner you say yeah I say stuff
like that oh boy he can't get enough of
it or he'll tell me how he's in pain and
I I try to not I try to not get sexually
aroused by his pain that's just in taste
he's like you're so sick and I'll make a
video and he sends it to his wife oh boy
and then she laughs but all you have is
it's about humor you [ __ ] I'm sorry
that yeah that issue with your that your
spine looks like an S and it's crushing
your [ __ ] lungs deal with it
my mom is my mom is is the comedy of the
family and she's like her side of the
family is I just sing and dance and it's
an Italian family my mom and dad are
Italian and my cute little mom who's
like you know she's this tiny little
cute potato and so she's 79 years old
and we just had a pacemaker put in which
is an amazing thing nowadays like an
outpatient it's very fast it's a couple
hours really yeah it's like two or three
hours what is and it's local local
anaesthetic she does not go to sleep
pacemaker basically you know they make
an incision they put it they put it just
like right and they just put it in a low
they can put it on the right but they
usually put it on the left and a and
area and there they send a little
electrode a little wire down into the
meat of the heart yeah and if it goes
below whatever the doctor amazing
decides different beats per heart rate
per minute it just shocks it to keep it
going
so my cute little mom had a pacemaker
put in and so we're going in there and
she's
into the into the you know bed and
they're about to wheel her off and stuff
and so she got into her smock and she's
getting into the thing and she's always
getting around and she says to the nurse
she goes I hope I have a girl this time
that's married I didn't know what the
nurse didn't know what the that's yeah
constantly you know I just think that
there's never a place where humor
doesn't work I think it's important and
I think sometimes it doesn't work when
you're on you know stage but yeah you
know sometimes things can be so brutal
in life but for the moment I just mean
like it always get them laughing yeah
but if you're up there and people are
not really responding never happen find
you're a you're a [ __ ] dynamo and and
you crush the rooms that's right yeah
okay you know what that was not a that's
what everybody else well
Brian Collins one of the funniest people
on the planet okay I will give you that
yeah and absolutely all right Shh but
I'm paying you a compliment so just but
don't don't don't do that don't do that
hold on a second I don't deal well with
that don't [ __ ] shut up and shut up
so when I'm paying you a compliment shut
just shut up okay okay shut up for a
second so when you're [ __ ] so when
you're up on stage right and you're
shredding and you're killing yeah and
then you try something else that's new
you try something out yeah well it goes
over like [ __ ] nope doesn't that's not
funny yeah okay that's my [ __ ] the
complex point yeah watch you know
squeeze your balls a little too hard so
it hurts
good good there's it that's what sweet
fish that's how the Inuit find the polar
bear yeah I know when the fishing sweet
addition of swedish fish and he's over
in the 7-eleven parking lot and the
polar bear just backs his nuts up to
that air compressor a new pic and his
friends are like let's send a [ __ ]
femur bone into this [ __ ] polar
bear's neck he's eaten swedish fish and
sour keys
by the 7-eleven pushing his balls up
against the air compressor you hear it
mm-hmm
and they all pile in their [ __ ] Ford
f-150 and head over there and drive a
femur bone a sharpened femur up the
board just smashed the [ __ ] truck
into the bay right with because they've
attached the spirit in the front of the
[ __ ] right they got the thing all mad
maxed out with a bunch of bones Spears
in front and just yeah and [ __ ]
what's-his-face Tom Hardy on the front
of it like Tony polar bear liver I think
why I think it's got so much at vitamin
A or some kind of vitamin that you'll
[ __ ] die you'll just die overdose
that's an incredible like you'll bleed
out like it well your I think your body
won't be able to clot blood or some
crazy [ __ ] that's tremendous
yeah that it has that's its defense oh
yeah it's like go ahead and kill me but
if you eat my liver I'm too healthy for
you don't make you bleed don't eat my
[ __ ] liver [ __ ] that's a rookie
mistake to go right for the liver when
you kill a polar bear it's amazing I
don't buy meat it's amazing how these
animals have have advanced and how they
have evolved over the years you believe
that the world is ten thousand years old
and flat though right oh I do not I do
not sir you tell me nope you told me
recently spreading rumors now no I'm not
your honor bread this Christian
fundamentalist thing around me and I'm
not that guy yeah but Brian you said
that you said if I know my friend Brian
yeah careful
recently I'm not I'm not trying to
spread [ __ ] you claimed that the earth
is 10,000 years old and flat okay I
never said that well yes you're
spreading rumors now opinion and you
were you said you said on it was a while
ago okay careful man it was like about a
year and a half ago
you said by gum the world is 10,000
years old they buy and it's flat or Ted
Cruz will not be the next president of
the United States
I never said that's what you said I'm
sorry I didn't say that's reporting the
net stick your whole hand up your ass
Omega all right good I love having sweet
fish on on hand you could [ __ ] it
does control me you low esteem Bears got
low self-esteem he'll do anything I do
anything sweet fish you just cut cut his
claws off and he just [ __ ] pushes his
hog it's not let's go to some current
events cuz I got [ __ ] to do I got a kung
fu class I have to get to and everything
else
he was yeah all right well this is I
don't want to bum everyone out but yeah
it's in the news right nice cause I was
watching on Instagram these buildings
fall down
yeah hexaco I mean wow it's really too
much it's a heavy situation so nice the
earth just shrugs and goes get off me
also in Mexico the building standards
are probably not not that up to par no
they're not and there's a little clip of
this video I saw this for what you're
watching a video have to be filosophy
holdings that's her building people gets
in that yellow building behind them okay
oh no remember buildings mostly air the
World Trade Centers for ninety five
percent air it's air right it's all air
and then it's just you know one one
thing falls on top of the other it's
it's you've seen a bunch of the
buildings cloths the same way too just
like they go straight down yeah they go
straight down Boyan structure is
compromised it falls in on itself that's
too much that's all I mean World Trade
Center didn't fall over there who could
have been had to be detonated because
that's the way it falls did it they put
do they put charges in there is that
what thee did guys I don't know you can
see or did they do that in or did maybe
Alex Jones has a theory on on the Mexico
earthquake there I got [ __ ] rocks day
yeah did the CIA do that today today
rich White Tower seven yeah they got
well they got the Hillary's a lizard and
she took tower seven and put charges in
it
yeah and they make a [ __ ] frogs day
all right take it easy Alex well why
don't you tell me why the tower seven
fell on its own well if you're so I'm
here with a Navy SEAL yeah I'm a Navy
SEAL
I I am I'm a Navy SEAL I own 87 dogs and
all of them were trained by Nate and
when I was the governor of Minnesota I
had over a hundred dogs now what say you
to that well if you're such a patriot I
don't know know how 9/11 you know what
happened what's that I guess she wants
to been there I'm I guess you must have
been there I wasn't and Nate would tell
you that oppressive canario that six
presa canarios could say take down a
building because that's not factual I
was not gonna say that I was gonna say
they could four of them could take out a
nuclear submarine it's not free I had
them doing it in the Marines I don't
know about that I was a Navy SEAL I know
you were you said I live in the Baja all
right I don't I I spent less than six
months a year in the continental United
States of America I have a thousand
gallons of potable water don't know how
yes and I have a silo full of tortilla
okay but what is the point of what the
what is that why don't you tell me I
don't know ma'am tell me why don't you
tell me what the point right as follow
you're such a patriot I am a patriot but
you know just because you have a silo
file we want to show us pictures of
shaven and shorn chimps and you and
you've never stepped in the in the in
the arena of battle with a chimp and
when I do you'll be thumbing your ass
for sure because I have gone in
hand-to-hand combat with many chips you
have yes armed only with a polar bear
femur and that's something you don't
know anything about because you I'll be
over there
in Danang and I'll be over there on the
Ho Chi Minh Trail there's no chance
there and and I'll take the chimps in
with me while you're over here taking
patty take lessons I'm not I with your
body now war is over and Vietnam war
never started what what what did you
just say I said the Vietnam War started
so that it could never end never stir
circuit I've never said that you I don't
know I don't you tell me what I said I
don't [ __ ] know I'm trying to tell
you Jesse I'll tell you what I
what did you say I said the Vietnam War
was started by chimpanzees why don't you
tell me why I am telling you the more
fair why nation sign in order so what
did the chimps do they started the war I
wrestled Bob Backlund for 45 minutes in
the Philadelphia spectrum well fine but
that does one draw it doesn't make so
why don't you tell me how all right you
know what get him out of here
all right fine ha leave bye-bye damn
that guy's that guy so hard to follow
[ __ ] is he doing I don't know man he's
just [ __ ] Jesse Ventura just runs in
here and [ __ ] your podcast yeah he
doesn't he's in control so no sense yeah
well there's security here for real he's
huge so what do you guys a big guy yeah
all right anything all right anyway
sorry about that guys all right let's
move off in New Mexico quake god bless
everybody I hope mm-hmm I hope they pull
through with this it sucks
I don't yeah it's it's yeah I mean
what's what can you say nothing it's too
much now it's just too much than the
best um the next one sequel to Judgment
Day the part two which was an amazing
one the best one she's coming back Linda
Hamilton and Schwarzenegger yes yeah but
they're basing it off and uh like a new
character but they'll be in the movie oh
that's cool she was fantastic right in
Terminator 2
that's the way she cocked that shotgun
yeah all of our memories and when a
happy bear thumbs is nub he's usually
the first women on screen to have like
exhibits and yeah and and Delta me she
had she worked her ass it was it was it
was she was a bad [ __ ] who was
sexy as hell and and yeah her [ __ ] in
that movie was man oh man when she's
like doing the chin-ups when you first
see her oh yeah she's in the batter side
down oh she's doing [ __ ] ups and they
just beaten the living [ __ ] out of guys
and a lot of people would be like oh
well yeah you know when you're watching
a movie it's like yeah right that girl's
just kicking the [ __ ] out of five guys
sometimes it's not done that well in
movies this is one of those things where
it's like oh yeah she's kicking the
living tar out of these three guards who
come in yeah man it was [ __ ] yeah I
give a [ __ ] how big you are when you
take the
the butt of a shotgun to the face you're
gonna drop to your knees and that's
something you've never felt Bryan Callen
and I know yeah a thing or do i I've
served with women in the Marines I said
you're in the seals right I was in the
Navy SEALs okay but you said the Marines
just well I did not say that that's not
what I said
just I said don't I had a secret I had a
secret team of a dozen women and me I
don't and we would go yes we would and
we went to Cambodia together and then
what did you do at Camp oh he took out
the enemy and then we had sex we had sex
have you ever had out 13 some I've never
had a fight have all right you're not a
patriot if you haven't had a 13 son I
don't think that's a good man 12 Navy
SEALs built like Linda Hamilton and I'll
tell you another thing
what they sure did [ __ ] my shotgun that
day okay I got it
Jesse you got to get out of here right
now we're doing fine bye-bye tell them
he's a giant they don't be they're not
gonna see I'm not gonna stop them with
the [ __ ] celebrities a piece of paper
that says you recording in he's the
governor of Minnesota stop the governor
all right all right so good I'm looking
forward to this I'm glad Linda Hamilton
is working that sucks
she'd been out of work for a while and
she's great actor we were saying to how
James Karen was the first person to
really bring a girl make her toe yeah in
a movie yeah you know how like there's a
lot of 56 year-old tough guys now in
movies there's no female version of it
so that's why that's one of the reasons
he's bring her back yeah
Sigourney yes Barney and then you got
Sigourney but okay this one I remember
we played this before a guy dropping his
ring yep
when proposing yeah and it went to under
the bridge and it landed in the water
they could never find it
yeah no oh man so what is this look at
these ladies
oh very sad they did a GoFundMe page
yeah for the goal of like 3000 it only
had like a hundred something dollars and
it closed so it's really sad and jimmy
kimmel invited him over to his studio on
TV and check it out this is Neil Lane
from they bring out Neil Lane a jeweler
[Music]
special for you okay so that with Orion
and Rey years by the way this guy Ryan
that's you in ten years dude how awesome
I love our country we never got to hide
time anyways it's a long one but they
recreated it they had the set built at
the studio and he redid it it was great
it was bad it's so cool as I think I
love that you know what I think what I
think that's very sweet
yeah it is sweet you know what I think
what I think it's very sweet
okay you're getting emotional and I
think that um it makes me think music
like mm-hmm
like waitress with Sara Bareilles and it
makes me think of that song the cheese
thing you ever said do you have a song
for these two yep
you covered your mouth away you drop
that I would never
we braided your hair and I wore my
glasses on when on Jimmy
you are pink and she is brown
nothing wrong with that we're gonna have
kids with red hair and they're gonna get
teased at school okay and they eat lots
of taro root and spam and rice and they
mash it together in the morning
never go home free they are strong he is
clumsy but he is strong she would eat a
polar bear and save some for him after
they smash it into their compression
take another friend of the Sun but he
starts to smolder almost immediately
he's never been home with her to San
Diego where she's from because it's too
hard
he's a Wisconsin born Wisconsin Oh
what's gone to now by no and he loves to
eat cheese in the Mall of America knock
his glasses off and shoot him in the ass
down the up why that's too mean put him
in the Sun of barium to his neck drop
and that [ __ ] ring to the neck and
put him in the Sun for dropping that
[ __ ] ring teach him a lesson
he's not Jimmy Kimball but the next show
he's on they gotta fire fire fire fire
never tell you about speaking of
listening yeah we talk about speaking of
San Diego one time I was at a charger
game with my good buddies
Cyrus and help me and we were we were at
the game and there were these two kids
behind us these two like 20 year old
kids were just hammered right and
they're being such dicks but they were
funny and then in front of us we're at a
Steelers game I'm a Steeler fan and so
we're sitting you know over their San
Diego these guys behind us or San Diego
fans guys in front row of Steeler fans
right all together one guy in a written
Raiders gear whatever he is
it was just let your mind run wild it
was fantastic
this guy starts John with the kids he's
like yeah but you guys paid primo dollar
for your tickets just being a douchebag
he's like he goes you know what I paid
man I paid nothing I know so-and-so and
I got these you and he literally and the
guys like yeah whatever ass [ __ ] you and
they're on his ass and we're in the
middle of this he turns around he's
making the money signed with his fingers
and thumbs he's like you don't have any
money you don't have takes out a
hundred-dollar bill and he's like yeah
you see and the guy just goes you like
and takes the hundred-dollar bill the
kids the whole sections laughing this
dude sitting in front of us
looks like this guy he's like this
redheaded dude he's out there in a visor
his skin is a bright shade of neon red
at this point it's the fourth quarter
he's had like you know 10 Miller Lite
yeah and he's just ruddy and he sits so
he's so Sun blasted and he's just
sitting there steaming he's had enough
of these two guys and we're at o'clock
and he's had enough of thee of the
teenagers or the teenage yeah he's with
the Raiders fan and they were all like
you know they were all like my age and
then these kids were behind us it was so
funny we're just like he's gonna blow
man look at this teakettle he's gonna
blow he turns around he goes he just
stands up and he gets in their face and
he goes let me tell you guys something
and the kid one of the kids without
missing a beat goes I got the alcohol
face the whole section laughs again and
the dude just turns around sits down oh
my god I was dying and he just clammed
it back up and he just pushed it back
down where it started in elementary
school and I empathize with him I
sympathize very we've all been there in
our own ways and this man was bullied by
people half his age yeah and and I'm
sorry but it was he was okay he had his
row of friends but he shouldn't have
started with the 20 year old buddy my
buddy my father's my father's friend
sweet guy but was a complete nerd in
high school and teased and he bought
this top line poor she made a fortune
and drove his Porsche to his high school
reunion and was just like I'm gonna show
them and my dad said how'd it go and he
to his credit he said you know what dude
I realized I was just a nerd with a
Porsche oh boy he's still a nerd that's
not and my dad gave him the middle
finger and slapped his [ __ ] mouth
what no you did not Fatima sweet face no
Big Mike did not do that don't say that
about your digits I see that's karajan's
and he's still in the garage
don't blame your your miss happenings
and your horrible behavior on Big Mike
I'm just telling you what happened no
that's not what happened you can say
what you want but I'm just telling you I
did
well I guess that's I guess that's the
end of that I hear what you're saying
completely but also no okay well let's
see what good argument event it I'm
really glad these guys made it out of
that yeah they're very cute they're cute
they're [ __ ] adorable is what they
are they are Q and they got a ring and
then they're gonna go to their ten-year
anniversary with the ring and then you
know not gonna get someone's gonna get
in his face and say I have a haba haba
yep that is the last current event sweet
I would do a dropping knowledge but it's
just too serious and you know what
though III read an interesting thing on
we break into teams right human beings
are tribal apes and something to keep in
mind is that people love to fight over
the most mundane things the Protestant
and Catholic wars that went on over
probably almost a hundred years at least
60 years the hundreds of thousands of
people that were killed between
basically Christians that believed in
the exact same God believed in the exact
same Bible and this is all in Europe
this is after the Reformation
you know what the Reformation is do you
guys know what the Reformation is when
Martin Luther who was a German priest
nailed the hundred proclamations to the
door in Bittan Berg Germany I believe it
was one of the most significant events
in history because this this Jesuit
priest basically said hey as a Catholic
I guess it to be a good Catholic I
basically I have a hierarchy which is
the priest starting with the Pope at the
top the Pope was as close to God as you
get and the priest basically would tell
me you know there was a hole there were
rituals you would do good acts you would
go to confession you would take Holy
Communion but there was a ritual you
would go to church he would read in
Latin nobody spoke Latin but you'd have
to listen to him and he was the
authority the priest the Cardinal the
bishop they were the authorities and
they would not be questioned and many
times you would do the church favors
whether and by the way sometimes there
was sexual that there was a lot of
corruption what and yeah and they and
you would get you would get what was the
word for it but essentially they had the
keys to heaven and
Pope for sure but you know the priest
would pray for you and you would have a
better chance of getting in heaven along
comes Martin Luther who says it's not
about doing good deeds it's not about
all these rituals it's not about praying
the saints it's not about even going to
church it's about the grace of God
reading the Bible if you read the Bible
and you believe and you live a good life
then you essentially are a Protestant
you don't need this massive hierarchy
that starts in Rome and with this with
all these like you know high priests
essentially that was radical that was
what they called heresy which with
you're a heretic it means you're
speaking against the church and he had
to leave Bitburg and everything else but
the bottom lines he started a
Reformation and a lot of people went
yeah to be a man of God or a woman of
God I don't need the Catholic Church I
just need the Bible so that's where
Protestant church came along and and I'm
paraphrasing the history here but if you
ever notice how Catholic churches have
stained glass they've got pictures of
saints they've got a lot of
ornamentation Protestant churches are
basically very very stark houses where
you come in and pray but there's not a
lot of iconography or anything else
because that was considered a bit that
wasn't considered like you know that was
considered very kind of almost idol
worship it was it was considered all you
need it was the Bible and and a preacher
or not even long story short over the
years there's basically really a long
you're right the st. Bartholomew's
massacre and I'm [ __ ] this out
because I'm not gonna get it exactly
right but the same father masters when
Catholics came in to a French town and
killed something like ten thousand
French Protestants you know men women
and children because the Catholics
believe that you have to do good deeds
Catholics bleed you have to go through
the rituals of the church that they grew
up with and a good Christian does good
deeds and here's the irony and so they
go into a Protestant village people are
present and killed about 10,000 of them
we and it was called the st.
Bartholomew's massacre the the Pope was
so overjoyed at the news that not only
did he essentially hold a day of Prayer
sort of festivities but then he had a
commission and artist to draw the
recreation of the massacre it's called
st. Bartholomew's massacre and it's in
the Vatican in one of the rooms and
guess what that room is closed to the
public now this is not a bat and it's
not the bash the Catholic Church what
this is is this is how human beings
behave and this is how little it takes
two kids
people love to draw teams people love to
get on one side and go you know what you
don't believe you should do good acts
you just believe all you need is the
Bible I'm gonna kill you and vice versa
by the way a lot of Protestant killing
of Catholics a lot of Catholics killing
a province they believe in the same God
there were vicious Wars they tore Europe
apart and they lasted for almost a
hundred years you thank you everybody
that that's really really I did not know
by the way I would also add that the
Protestant Catholic wars in Ireland in
Northern Ireland raised and they were
brutal now a lot of that had to do with
loyalty to the crown to England but it
also had its division with Catholicism
and Protestantism the Anglican Church
the the English church and the
Protestant church I will not I will not
comment so much on religions place in a
modern world some would say it's been
replaced by the internet that is not my
place here to preach from any sort of
pulpit we have a point of view I will
say that I was raised Roman Catholic
that's a fact and I will say that you
have a lovely Venice mural here on the
wall that I'm looking at and if you say
one more word against God I will I
didn't say place this mayoral with a
mural of me I beating the [ __ ] out of
you now and we'll call it st. Hyde
Ryan's Massacre I didn't say that and no
I didn't say that you're you know my
parents were never all that religious
you know I had to go to summer school or
Sunday School and I did you know I got
the Holy Communion and all that stuff
and then I went my own way with my own
you know religion spirituality that's
nobody's business yeah but I will say
yeah you you talk like that again
now I didn't now now hold on we're gonna
I'm gonna take you out to the parking
lot now
see and we're gonna have people gonna
take pictures whole point is friend
we're gonna give those to artists no we
believe you're not beautiful Marone
believe the same God now well everyone
believes in the same just try God
because human beings are looking up to
the Sun I'm going but I know what's it
all about
you call a daughter [ __ ] all our uma
or Oprah that's whatever you want to say
I mean we should resort to violence and
I was just trying to say that this
doesn't have to be the st. Bartholomew's
massacre and it won't be it won't be
immoral miss go to mix mental arts.com
where i did a great podcast with
Thaddius russell about the difference
between plural truths and fixed truths i
look forward to listening to that had
the idea that belief in a fixed truth in
one truth is the most destructive idea
in history we had a bit of an argument
about it why what do you mean what was
the argument well you know their idea
that so you have to be very careful with
people love to have the truth this is
what ideology is ideology is that
ideology is so there there if you were a
communist
I mean people the communist movements
based on the idea we have we have the
economic truth the truth is it's in Das
Kapital and the Communist Manifesto Karl
Marx and Friedrich Engels they came up
with the the seal on economic science
now we know now that there is no CEO on
economic science economics is a very
complicated thing but whenever well this
is the difference between between
religion and philosophy philosophy deals
with reason and and and logic and
mathematics to try to prove a point but
it's always moving science is the same
way science is basically admitting your
own ignorance okay
and and using models simulation and the
recreation of phenomena with models and
experimentation to prove a point and get
closer to the truth when Muhammad the
prophet in Islam said I am the seal of
all the prophets in other words it this
is it for me I it starts and ends with
me that I'm the last prophet to speak to
God here is the truth you don't need
anymore
that is what religion is that is what
ideology is whether it's communism
whether it's Christianity that you have
to be careful with these things to so
when you believe in something and it's a
fixed truth and you say this is the only
truth the discussion is over you have
you have you become a fanatic because
anybody other anyone
who has a different point of view
anybody has an interpretation of
Christianity or Islam both by the way
both those religions can be interpreted
in many different ways so I'm being a
little unfair they've always been very
very you know but but so be careful
about thinking you have the truth with a
capital T
you probably don't the truth is there
are a lot of different truths you know
what Brian you're absolutely right about
that in Canada we have saying that I
believe trumps all of the all of the
what a zealot would think what an idea
an ideology that one would hold a truth
that one would hold on to despite
despite the cries of people just despite
the the buildings of the heart and it
Trump's it trumps all of that yeah and
it's just a very simple adage it's a
simple not saying it's a philosophy in
itself yeah well okay another day back
to this and it's a hold on I haven't
even said it yet yeah here we go this is
what we say in Canada ready sure and if
people just did things the Canadian way
I'm originally from Canada yeah I'm a
citizen of both countries though so
don't say Oh we'll shut up yeah just a
Canadian go back cuz you're never
getting rid of me America I am a citizen
of these United States yeah I vote in
your elections I take part in your
economy so as an American I can say this
legally yeah suck my dick okay now hold
on okay I'm sorry I'm saying as an
American no I know but hold on yeah let
me just I'm an American I can say what I
want First Amendment protects me okay
suck my [ __ ] [ __ ] okay bro hold on
you're being so rude right now hold on
yeah I'm not saying this to you okay
yeah feel like you are suck my fat dick
to anybody hold on I'm trying hold on
conversation about drugs hold on pleural
clips this is what I'm saying get my fat
hog hard and put it in your mouth hi now
said that six thought we get it yeah
okay that's I'm saying I can say that as
an as an American citizen yeah that's
like that but but I'm gonna tell you
what we say in Canada that would dispel
all of the all of the and I am NOT going
to make light of the of the V as Carl
Sagan calls it the rivers of blood that
have been spilled from one side of this
[ __ ] pebble
to the other yeah I'm paraphrasing yeah
when I based on the fact that we have
the truth you guys are wrong right Leah
and people have have beliefs in these
ideologies these these quote-unquote our
truth is rooted in love and sure your
your your are your side is rooted and
evil and falsehood so we're gonna kill
you right so we're gonna kill you does
right that's what the Protestant
Reformation was that's right Brett we're
bringing it full circle it's not it's
the communism was versus caplets no it's
no it's no it's nothing short of all I'm
an ism is the way anybody else is wrong
we kill you and Stalin killed what are
you the twenty million people are more
than that yeah Pol Pot did so and so and
look at mount a tongue marks a tongue
said was like 50 million people yeah
piece of [ __ ] starved his own people
yeah [ __ ] that guy so with respect all
that we have the answer in Canada you
ready yeah I would love for all your
listeners and especially the diamond
listeners of the ten minute podcast yeah
because they are dying this we're
whittling down because yeah that's right
we're gonna get that one diamond listen
yeah but listeners of both podcast and
everyone within the reach of my voice I
would love for you to share in this
Canadian philosophy ready yeah be a good
[ __ ] be a good [ __ ] up I'm gonna write a
religious book you know it's gonna be
both might be a good shitty [ __ ] why
didn't you know what it's gonna say in
the inside it's gonna be one page book
you know why I think you know why what's
it gonna say inside say [ __ ] that's
right be good [ __ ] for words gonna say
be good [ __ ] our blogs gonna say right
so that's the one bag its book you know
to buy it it's gonna say be a good [ __ ]
I'll buy it I just
you ugly you guys already know the book
yeah why would you buy a book that you
already know welcome I'm not selling it
to you just remember will that sign the
book will the book of Willa gin [ __ ] off
well the book of Willa jaw and you
remember religion not from when our time
together
yeah for many podcast of course at the
ten minute podcast yeah you understand
Willa gin yeah and you know that the
decree is be a good try it look just and
if you don't want to be a good [ __ ] yeah
suck my dick alright
and the point is making is it just be
responsive to evidence right oh that's
an American ideologue don't don't just
join a team and think Jews you don't
have the [ __ ] [ __ ] teams man [ __ ] to
that out there by yourself
Oh
you know Malone wolf you know that
you're a lone wolf tonight Oh ain't no
bear back back your balls up in that
[ __ ] blanket buzzing hey go burn the
balls daga there you go yeah I don't
want to eat anymore yes [ __ ] I can't
eat in your tiny little one anymore
little piece I talk in there this has
been a real [ __ ] sowed yeah it's good
stuff it's always great to be here Brian
I always liked doing
I want to thank anything thank you well
for an a charmer thanks for showing up
one of these days dude we're gonna let
people in on how we actually talk yeah
but until then I'm just gonna be full of
[ __ ] on your podcast all right man well
I will sit here and goof Lou
now [ __ ] that I don't think your
listeners would like that now let me
just show up not [ __ ] dick around
like an insecure [ __ ] you know yeah
dip dip [ __ ] as we leave maybe give it a
little word to everybody everybody out
there still afraid what should they do
everyone's afraid of stuff yeah
everyone's got their own issues okay so
what do we do we'll give it leave us
with with it drops knowledge for us oh
no I'm not gonna get emotional
well I just had some sugar so I'm
feeling a high from the sugar and I got
emotion don't cry no I stuffed it down
with us mmm give ah [ __ ] with the food I
will give us something here cuz you're
an emotional eater mmm come on you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] bear I'll help you up I'll
help everybody out
do you [ __ ] digit everybody has
different problems mind you bear just
every problem is okay they're sitting
there always don't eat don't put it in a
sandwich all right man you know this is
gonna [ __ ] disaster this is a fighter
and a kid we're out